[Música]
y
para que todos los seres humanos en
algún momento de nuestra vida hemos
encontrado obstáculos muy fuertes en el
camino como esa mujer de pacaya en
guatemala cuando la erupción del volcán
que no encuentra su hijo las vivimos las
vemos situaciones en las cuales las
personas sufren profundas
profundas tragedias que es lo que nos
ayuda a seguir adelante en donde es que
encontramos la fuerza para sobreponernos
a este tipo de situaciones
sin duda hay gente extraordinaria que
tiene una gran capacidad para
sobreponerse a lo que sea aquí les pongo
a gabi nuestra medallista olímpica que
tiene más de 70 medallas internacionales
y que es un ejemplo de constancia y de
voluntad y de dedicación pero la mayoría
de los mortales no tenemos esa
extraordinaria capacidad nos las
arreglamos para vivir y para para
sobrevivir ojalá tuviéramos esa energía
creo que si hay gente extraordinaria que
tiene una capacidad de resiliencia
extraordinaria pero el resto de las
personas no podemos nosotros solitos
cuando menos no es lo que yo creo
y yo encuentro bueno la resiliencia es
algo que se dice que se da en
condiciones de adversidad pero creo que
la resiliencia es algo que se construye
solamente de manera colectiva que nadie
puede ser fuerte solito que siempre
necesitamos de los demás para poder ser
fuertes que son nosotros quienes nos dan
esa fuerza porque mucho se viene
hablando en los últimos años en el
discurso de la resiliencia que es algo
que se puede enseñar como si fuera una
clase que es algo que se puede
desarrollar mediante una programación
neurolingüística
la resiliencia no viene solo de tu
interior que sí es importante viene de
los que te hacen resiliente aunque no
quieras muchas veces los que te sacan
adelante a pesar de ti mismo en
ocasiones entonces la resiliencia si se
puede dar en situaciones de desgracia
pero no de manera no de manera
individual
y la resiliencia viene de a veces de un
libro a veces de una película que vimos
a veces de una maestra eternamente
presente en nuestra mente como diseño
lupe pinedo que me decía la palabra no
puedo no existen diccionario pues ya
tienes que volverlo a intentar y siempre
se me quedó grabado porque a veces que
me sentía desanimada me acordaba la
palabra no puedo no existe en el
diccionario entonces esa vez es esa cosa
ese consejo que nos dio la mamá y ese es
el chip que tenemos ya grabado
interiorizado en nosotros el que nos
hace seguir adelante
si es cierto se da en situaciones de
desgracia pero porque se da que es lo
que hace que un niño como este niño de
tuxpan cuando la inundación de provocada
por el huracán huila se dedicó a salvar
perritos no este que es lo que lo hace
que no solamente no estaba pensando en
el mismo sino que estaba pensando en los
demás creo que ahí allí encontramos la
razón de la resiliencia ese niño es un
sobreviviente y ese niño es un
resiliente porque no piensa solamente en
sí y ahí fue donde encontró las fuerzas
para ponerse a hacer algo que cualquier
otro niño no hubiera no hubiera hecho
la resiliencia viene pues es algo que se
tiene que trabajar en los espacios
educativos pero no es algo que se pueda
enseñar yo no puedo dar clases de
resiliencia como se enseña a vencer la
adversidad quien es el sabio que tiene
la receta para vencer la adversidad sin
embargo la educación sirve no estarán de
acuerdo conmigo que la educación sirve
para generar resiliencia que cuando
nosotros estudiamos y leemos y buscamos
comprender algo nos hacemos más fuertes
encontramos muchas respuestas
encontramos otros locos otros cómplices
que nos pueden acompañar en el camino
entonces sí sí se puede adquirir
resiliencia en la educación no se puede
enseñar resiliencia a través de un acto
educativo porque es algo que se
construye
cuáles son las fuentes de esa
resiliencia
pues fundamentalmente el sentir que
perteneces a algo el sentir que tienes
una identidad como nuestras comunidades
víricas para las que toda la simbología
que representan sus vestuarios y sus
costumbres son la fuerza que les ha
permitido sobrevivir y prosperar a
través de los años
entonces cuando te sientes fuera de tu
comunidad cuando te sientes ajeno eres
menos resistente eres más vulnerable que
cuando te sientes rodeado apapachado por
tú por tu familia por tu comunidad
otra razón de la resiliencia es el
sentir que este que estamos haciendo
algo algo útil por los demás el sentir
que que nuestra vida no es solamente
valiosa para nosotros sino para alguien
más aquí les pongo a gabi un estudiante
mía que es una de las personas más
resilientes que conozco porque se dedica
a estar siempre buscando qué causa va a
ser de reciclaje de reforestación de
beccar niños se tiene es una persona
extraordinaria que vuelca su vida en
ayudar a los demás y eso la hace
levantarse cada día y eso la hace que
nada la pueda detener a pesar de que
tiene sus cuotas también de dificultades
por las que ha atravesado
y bueno la mayor fuente de resiliencia
el amor el sabernos queridos el saber
que a alguien le importamos un y así
desea grande chico como se puede sentir
que alguien nos ama yo creo que no hay
nada que te haga sentir tan valioso
porque no nos podemos amar nosotros
solos en un cuarto oscuro el amor es una
construcción social es un acto en
colectivo como cuando llega mi nieto y
me abraza y me aprieta como que no me va
a soltar nunca digo si algo le puede dar
a uno en la vida fuerzas para lo que sea
es sentir que hay alguien a quien le
importa tanto
o bueno decía yo como les voy a enseñar
resiliencia como enseñar resiliencia a
mis estudiantes si ellos son la causa de
mi resiliencia como les enseño que ellos
son que son sus miradas que esos que su
interés que es que su cariño el que me
hace que siga 38 años después de haber
empezado a ser maestra con el mismo
entusiasmo de volver cada día no importa
lo que pase no importa que no nos paguen
porque voy a ver algo que valoro mucho
más que nada y aquí les pongo prudencia
prudencia es un chico que un día me
pidió prestados 500 pesos
y para pagar mails
y fue a pagarme los con toda la
dificultad que le implicó reunir el
dinero para pagarme los pero prudencia
también porque un día que le preguntaba
para qué era la educación y me decía es
que los maestros deben amar a sus
estudiantes para que reciban en la
escuela el amor que no tienen en su casa
digo
son mi inspiración son mi fuente de
resiliencia no es algo que yo pueda como
se los voy a dar si es lo que estoy
recibiendo de ellos pero así bueno
empecé yo a decirme
hablando de amor aquí tengo mi
fantástica y anormal familia que es la
fuente también de mi fuerza mis
compañeras siempre presentes
les decía yo que a lo mejor si les puedo
enseñar resiliencia
no resiliencia a través de la educación
ni cómo ser resilientes les puedo
enseñar porque yo formo profesores
y ser profesor es una inmensa fuerte de
resiliencia si ellos me ven a mí lo que
deja en mí la energía que me da el ser
maestro les están enseñando a ser
resilientes y creo que tengo muchos
ejemplos y muchas vivencias estos chicos
que están aquí escogieron un día
llamarme la tía margaret a
y entonces discutíamos a propósito de
freire que decía freire que deberíamos
de ser maestras no tías porque el día
que es un término que se usa mucho en
brasil o en chile para nombrar a las
maestras de preescolar para hacerlas más
cercanas a los niños decía pedir que
esto adormece su lucha social adormece
el reclamo por mejores condiciones de
vida y entonces que había que decirles
díaz y que pues yo no estoy de acuerdo
con freire y está y me puse escribirles
unos piensos que se llamaban freire el
amor y la tía margarete y pues ya no me
he podido quitarlo de la piel margarete
por andar les por andar les poniendo eso
porque creo sí que la educación es un
acto de amor que es un acto de amor en
el que te tienes que entregar te tienes
que dar que tienes que poner lo mejor de
ti porque es muy valioso y es muy
importante la capacidad que tienes de
influir en la vida de los demás para
bien o para mal
quien nos recuerda por ahí algún maestro
esos terroristas que influyeron en su
vida pero para peor o algún maestro que
te hizo sentir que podías alcanzar el
cielo ya tenemos esa enorme capacidad de
liderazgo y esa capacidad
el reconocerme maestro y reconocerme por
ello
líder líder obligado a asumir esa
función del liderazgo es una causa
enorme enorme de resiliencia pues ahí
les dejo mis chiquillos a esta prudencia
también en un rinconcito
y así vamos construyendo en nuestra
escuela en donde yo trabajo una
comunidad de aprendizaje nos llamamos
una tribu nos llamamos una tribu porque
llegamos todos de diferentes lados y
duramos un tiempo viviendo en la tribu y
eventualmente se vuelve a separar la
gente para ir a formar otras tribus
nunca dejas de ser parte de la tribu
siempre llevas el tatuaje de la tribu
grabado en ti pero no es algo que vayas
a permanecer siempre yo soy la vieja de
la tribu actualmente pero es una tribu
así comprometida solidaria emprendedora
que nos ayudamos unos a otros si por
algo yo no me he jubilado es porque
formo parte de una comunidad que se
preocupa los unos por los otros y esa es
mi fuente de resiliencia muchas veces
cuando analizan los empleadores
en la permanencia en el trabajo han
encontrado que la mayor el mayor motivo
para permanecer en un trabajo no es el
sueldo ni las condiciones laborales son
los compañeros de trabajo a veces te
quedas en un trabajo en que el trabajo
lo odias porque te encanta la gente con
la que trabajas
qué trabajas o porque te encariñas te
con ellos o porque ya no los quieres ya
no te quieres deshacer de ellos a veces
medio los odias pero pero prefieres
vivir con ellos
así entonces tenemos esta enorme tribu
esta maravillosa tribu
este en donde cada integrante de la
comunidad aquí están
mike edgard del tom gabi david y karim
que son estudiantes trabajadores
administrar este académicos juntos
porque se les pega la gana ponerse a
arreglar su escuela para que se vea más
bonita eso es realmente lo que te va
generando la resiliencia les importa el
lugar en el que están trabajando
otra fuente de resiliencia es el orgullo
el orgullo de saber que formas parte de
una institución educativa que formas
parte del mayor proyecto social que
puede tener la humanidad
porque lo que haces como maestro la
educación es contagiosa o sea ojalá
pudieran evitarla la educación es
perniciosa se mete por todos lados una
persona educada va a ir a cambiar las
vidas de las demás personas y el orgullo
de saber te formador de personas de
saberte maestro de saber que vas a
contribuir a dejar un mundo mejor que el
que te encontraste es una extraordinaria
fuente de resiliencia
y qué hay que hacer qué hay que hacer
para estimular a nuestros estudiantes a
que desarrollen esa resiliencia primero
darles espacios de creatividad dejarlos
que ellos protagonicen no quererles
decir cuál es la razón la verdad y la
vida porque bastante tenemos nosotros
con nuestros errores hay que dejarlos
que vuelen que experimenten en un
espacio seguro y cuál es nuestra chamba
pues admirarlos alentarlos orientarlos
pero sobre todo debemos detenerlos como
protagonistas yo disfruto enorme ver
estas es un grupo mis estudiantes
tomando una clase este manuel dulce toño
es una imagen de ya hace muchos años
pero se me quedan se me quedan grabadas
en el corazón porque para esto trabajo y
esto es lo que me da fuerza
y vemos así también que la resiliencia
no es nada más para que tú sobreviva la
resiliencia es para que no más para ti
ay sí un dos tres por mí y por todos mis
amiguitos
la resiliencia para quien la resiliencia
nada más vas a sobrevivir para triunfar
tú uno entre mil o algo así una
resiliencia tiene que hacer para hacer
un mundo mejor para ti para mí para
ellos para ellos que son quienes a
quienes nos debemos como humanidad si
nosotros cumplimos con esta con este
sentido de la resiliencia si nosotros
aprovechamos verdaderamente la fuerza
interior que tenemos no puede ser para
nosotros una vida con sentido una vida
plena no puede ser sólo para ti para
satisfacer tus intereses
y tus necesidades egoístas los tenemos
que tener muy claro que la resiliencia
el haber desarrollado esa capacidad
porque a veces muchas veces los jóvenes
piensan
que su vida no tiene sentido
y ya estaba buscando salidas extremas
porque siempre están buscando el sentido
de su vida al interior de ellos mismos
pero cuando el sentido de tu vida está
en hacer mejor la vida de los demás tus
problemas se ven tan chiquitos y es
tanto lo que puedes hacer entonces esta
es una parte que considero yo
fundamental de esta manera si nosotros
desarrollamos realmente una práctica de
resiliencia comunitaria una práctica de
resiliencia compartida en donde a veces
no te quieres ni levantar prueba en tus
amigas por ti te llevan las fuerzas la
resiliencia no es sólo tuya y es también
desde ese grupo de apoyo si nosotros
hacemos esto podremos un día
y seguir nuestro camino y dejarle
dejarle el lugar a los que vienen
caminando junto con nosotros muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]